- Let's wrap things up with one last story
to bring you cheer, hopefully.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
So it's crazy to think,
but many kids these days
have never written a letter.
I guess it's not as necessary
in a world of email and
text as it once was,
but handwritten letters have
a special kind of magic.
I love them.
That's why a Tennessee teacher is helping
her second graders embrace the power
of putting pen to paper.
She started a pen pal program
with a school 4,000 miles away in Alaska,
and it's teaching them some
deeply powerful lessons.
Let's get this teacher
on the line right now.
Hey, what's up, Diana? Hi.
- Hey. Hi, Kelly.
- Hello, well, first of all,
I have to say I had a pen
pal whenever I was a kid,
and it was the coolest thing ever.
We wrote to our pen pals in
school, and our teachers,
they did the same thing for
us, and it was in Africa,
and it was the coolest
thing, experience as a kid.
So, thank you.
- [Diana] Yeah.
- For doing this for your kids.
Why was it important to you?
- Well, for the one
thing, writing a letter
tells somebody you care.
You take the time to sit
down and write that letter,
and you become a part of history
when you put a date and
your name to that paper.
My grandmother wrote me,
and those letters are a treasure to me.
We started writing the letters.
We had the kids do three
things about themselves
and ask a question to your friend.
And when they got those letters
back, they went ballistic.
They were jumping and screaming.
It's like you'd given them a
million dollars or something.
My hope is that they
continue to write letters
the rest of their lives.
- Absolutely.
It is very special
when you get something that's handwritten.
That's really cool.
Thank you so much, Diana.
What you're doing for
these kids is so cool,
and you know, it's gonna
change them, I promise you.
It changed me as a kid.
It was the coolest thing ever.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Diana] Thank you. You're the best.
- And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the erasable go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you,
so they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
- Wow!
- [Kelly] That's a lot of envelopes.
- The kids are gonna love it.
- [Kelly] That's a lot
of envelopes and stamps.